EVE ANDERSSON: Today we're going to talk about
a free online course we've developed called
"Introduction to Web Accessibility." We will
learn about some of the tools and techniques
in this course for making websites more accessible
to people with vision impairments. My name
is Eve Andersson. I'm a manager in accessibility
engineering here at Google. And we have a
distinguished panel to my left of accessibility
experts. On my far left is Vint Cerf. He is
a VP at Google and our Chief Internet Evangelist.
Some have also referred to him as "one of
the Fathers of the Internet." We also have
Charles Chen, an engineer in accessibility,
and he's one of the developers of this course.
We have one more panelist who wasn't able
to be with us today. His name is T.V. Raman.
He is a research scientist at Google, and
he works on accessibility. He also helped
develop this course, and we'll see him later
in a video. All right, the first question
is for you, Vint. Vint, why should people
- why should software developers learn about
accessibility?
VINT: Well, let's start with a very fundamental
point: not all of the websites in the world
are readily accessible to people who need
some assistance. If you happen to be blind
or have vision impairment, you can't see the
web pages, and you can't interact with them
in the way others can. If you happen to be
deaf, or in my case, I'm hearing impaired,
there are times when you can't actually quite
make out the audio, and it would help a lot
if we could see captions or written material
to go along with it. There are other people
who have a variety of other problems that
have to be accommodated. And so this whole
notion is about assistance to make things
useful and accessible for everyone. The reason
that it's important to do that is twofold.
First it's the right thing to do. We want
everyone to take advantage of and be able
to use the benefits and fruitful content available
on the internet. But perhaps more important,
it's ironic that the one tool that's been
invented in the last several years - the computer
- is the one thing that can, in fact, make
things accessible because it's so flexible.
We can write programs to adapt and accommodate.
And yet that's the one area that has been
poorly treated for many, many years. It's
almost as strange as the telephone invented
by Alexander Graham Bell intending to help
the deaf and being useless to them until somebody
finally invented things like email and teletypes
and so on. So we have an obligation to take
this new technology and make it work for everyone
on the planet regardless of the needs that
they may have for assistance.
EVE: Thank you, Vint. So one of the things
you said was that we want the web to work
for everyone, and it currently doesn't. Charles,
could you show us what the web looks like
to someone who's blind?
CHARLES: Sure, Eve. So if we switch to my
screen here, I have a very simple example
running. And what you'll see is that-- I'm
going to go over it twice. The first time
I'm going to show you what it looks like visually.
And then I'll show you what someone with a
visual impairment would experience the site
as. So as you can see, I have this page up
here. It looks like a simple enough page.
It has a title, "Button and Alert." There's
a button, and if I click it, I'll get an alert.
So I'm just going to click it with the mouse,
click it. "The button has been pressed!" No
problems. But now let's see what a user with
a visual impairment would experience. So I'm
going to turn on my screen reader here.
CHROMEVOX: ChromeVox is ready. Button and
Alert Example tab.
CHARLES: All right, so now my screen reader
is enabled. Let me navigate through this,
and let's experience what I hear.
CHROMEVOX: Click the button below to generate
an alert. Smile image.
CHARLES: Smile image. OK, that was interesting.
CHROMEVOX: If this were a real page, we would
have more content here.
CHARLES: Wait. Where was the button? OK, maybe
it was the smile image. Let's try that.
CHROMEVOX: Smile image.
CHARLES: OK, I'm going to try and press Enter
to click it. Hm. OK, nothing's happening.
Well, I'm a really good screen reader user,
so I know that I can try to generate some
sort of fake click event. Let me try and force
click this.
CHROMEVOX: Clicked. Smile image.
CHARLES: It says I clicked it, but I'm not
hearing anything. As you can see, this is
a pretty broken experience, and it's really
difficult to use if you have a visual impairment,
even for something as simple as this page.
EVE: Thanks for that. As I said earlier, TV
Raman can't be with us here today. But we
spent some time with him yesterday, and we'll
see a video where he talks a little bit more
about the content of the course, about accessible
development, as well as how we came up with
doing this course.
TV RAMAN: When you put up a website or you
write a web page, you actually don't know
who your audience is. Your audience could
be in the United States. Your audience could
be worldwide. Your audience might be English
speaking. Your audience might be speaking
another language as their first language.
So it's all about reach. And if it's all about
reach, then optimizing your content to cater
to the widest variety of needs is something
in everybody's interest. We thought wouldn't
it be nice to try using this new medium of
online education to teach something that deeply
affects the online experience. So, can we
use this online medium of web courses and
web-based education to teach web developers
how to make their websites and web contents
maximally useful and usable to all of their
audience? So during this class, we will both
teach you how to enhance your content for
accessibility and then also teach you to use
tools that check whether you have done the
needed work to make your content accessible
and also give you an opportunity to use tools
that let you experience firsthand what your
site feels like to someone who cannot see
and is trying to listen to your site. So in
a nutshell, we'll teach you techniques for
enhancing your content. We will show you tools
that let you first check your content, and
you'll get warnings and tips on ways we can
fix it. And then you'll fix it and actually
be able to experience a before-and-after.
We want to keep things simple for this first
course. And so we are going to narrow down
and focus on things you can do when you create
your content to make it work well for users
who are blind or users who have low vision.
That isn't to say that those are the only
problems you need to worry about. But this
will get you a part of the way to starting
to think about accessibility and about all
your users. So when you think about accessibility,
don't think of it as something special for
a few users. Think of it as designing your
content and site so that it works for everyone
independent of their needs who might happen
to come to your site. Accessibility is really
about you reaching the maximum number of devices,
the maximum number of users, the maximum number
of needs and abilities. Our goal is to whet
your appetite and get you interested. And
at the end of the course, we will point you
at additional resources that will let you
deep dive into specific areas. So enjoy the
course, and I hope to see you at the other
end of this course, where you are making your
sites address a lot more of the accessibility
issues that arise.
EVE: So in the video, Raman gave us a brief
overview of the content of the course. And
he mentioned that there are tools that let
you as a web developer experience a website
as a blind person does, as well as to help
you make a site more accessible. Can you show
us a little bit more about these tools?
CHARLES: Sure, Eve. So the two tools that
we'll be using primarily in this course are
Accessibility Developer Tools and ChromeVox.
Both of these are extensions that are freely
available on the Chrome Web Store, and you
can go ahead and download them. As you can
see on my screen, I have these tools installed.
So let's start with Accessibility Developer
Tools. These tools are some really simple,
really quick audits that will tell you if
you have problems with your web page. Now
let's try running this audit on an example
and let's see what it tells us. So I'm going
to go to Tools - I'm going to bring up Developer
Tools. And now if I switch into my Audits
panel, I can select Accessibility and I can
ask it to run the audit. So I'm going to run
the audit, and you see right here I get a
warning. The warning tells me that images
should have an alt attribute. Let's go ahead
and try to fix this. Ah, smile.png. That's
why it was saying 'smile image' rather than
the actual text of the button. So let's try
and fix this. Let me switch over to my text
editor here. Okay, so here is where I have
the image. I'm going to go ahead and add alt
text that make sense: alt="I'm a button.
Click me! smiley face" Okay, so let's save
this, and let's go back to the page, and let's
see what the audit says this time. Okay, as
you can see, I no longer have that warning.
So that's good. That's definitely an improvement.
And now let's move on to the next tool, ChromeVox.
So ChromeVox is our screen reader for Chrome
OS. It's also available as a Chrome extension
that anyone can install and try out. As a
web developer, this tool is really nice because
it gives you a way to experience what a blind
user would experience directly in your browser
without any real additional setup aside from
just installing the extension and enabling
it. So I'm going to go ahead and enable the
extension now. And let's try running through
this page again and let's see what it sounds
like.
CHROMEVOX: ChromeVox is ready. Button and
Alert Example tab.
CHARLES: OK, so let's go ahead and read through
this page now.
CHROMEVOX: Click the button below to generate
an alert. I'm a button. Click me! Smiley face.
CHARLES: OK, so that's nice. It told me what
this button has, but let's see. CHROMEVOX:
If this were a real page, we would have more
content here.
CHARLES: OK, well, from the text of that image,
I got the impression that it's a button. But
it still didn't tell me that it was actually
a button from a screen reader's perspective.
Also, if I move over it, I think I still won't
be able to click it. Let's see.
CHROMEVOX: I'm a button. Click me. Smiley
face.
CHARLES: Yeah, OK, so I still can't activate
it. So I think we still need a little bit
of work here, so let's go ahead and fix this.
Now, the nice thing is, even though this is
a pretty broken experience that we're starting
with, it's relatively easy to fix and correct,
as I will proceed to demonstrate. So let me
switch back to the code. And now one of the
first things to fix is to make sure that this
is actually reported to screen readers as
a button. So I'm going to add an ARIA role:
role="button" that makes sense. And let's
also make this button focusable and respond
to the Enter key. So I'm going to put: tabindex="0"
and I'm going to add a keydown handler. And
of course, I need to write the function for
a keydown handler, which is really quick.
All right, so this should do the trick. Let's
reload and let's see what this is like.
CHROMEVOX: Window Button and Alert. Example
Button and Alert Example. I'm a button. Click
me! Smiley face. Button.
CHARLES: OK, so as you can see now, this time
it actually reported that it was a button.
And let's try clicking it. OK, this was a
little bit better. It responded to the Enter
key. But still, as a blind user, I wouldn't
have heard the message that came up. So let's
go ahead and let's fix that. So all I need
to do here is, because it's an alert, I just
give need to give it an ARIA role of alert:
role="alert" And let's try this again.
CHROMEVOX: Window Button and Alert. Example
Tab. Button and-- Button and Alert.
CHARLES: OK, so I'm going to try this again.
CHROMEVOX: Click the button below to generate
an alert. I'm a button, Click me! Smiley face.
Button.
CHARLES: And now I'm going to press Enter.
CHROMEVOX: The button has been pressed. Alert.
CHARLES: Yay! So now this all works. So as
you can see with just a little bit of code,
I was able to take a completely broken experience
and make it work reasonably well.
EVE: Thanks for that demo, Charles. So I saw
in that, that you were editing HTML and JavaScript.
CHARLES: Yes.
EVE: What do people need to know before they
can embark on this course? Who is this course
for?
CHARLES: Glad you asked that. So this course
is for web developers. You do need to have
some basic understanding of HTML, JavaScript,
and CSS. But really it's for all levels of
web developers. You don't necessarily have
to be a JavaScript ninja to do well in this
course.
VINT: Well, that looked pretty simple, actually.
CHARLES: Yeah, so I think what was helpful
here was that the starting design was actually
fairly simple, fairly straightforward. There
was nothing in the design itself that made
it inherently inaccessible. You have a button.
You click on it. You get a reaction. As such,
if the missing piece for accessibility is
at a technical level, where things aren't
labeled, or you don't have the right ARIA
properties, or you don't have the right keyboard
handlers, then it is really simple to take
these problems and address them. And you can
fix them in a short amount of time. And these
are also the type of solutions that we'll
be covering in the course. The course is a
great starting point to help you learn about
these fixes.
VINT: So I would take away from this example,
Charles, two things. First of all, the tool
that helped you discover that there was a
problem could be very helpful if you have
a significant amount of code - having something
staring over your shoulder and saying, "Don't
forget, you need to do something about that,"
I think is very helpful. And you demonstrated
that for at least some of the problems that
are identified, the fix is not all that hard.
I think that on a deeper level, though, understanding
how to create designs that can be made accessible
is a much tougher proposition. You really
have to put your head somehow in the same
place as someone who's using this with need
for assistance. And so although this course
is at the beginning, so to speak, at some
point I hope we can help people understand
what it means to do really good accessible
engineering. And that, of course, is the ultimate
objective to all of what we're trying to accomplish.
CHARLES: Absolutely, Vint. At a deeper level,
design matters, right? So having a good accessible
design or at least a design that can be made
accessible is key. We can do all the technical
fixes we want to, but that's not going to
compensate for a really bad design if you
start with that.
VINT: Exactly right.
EVE: So how can people do accessible design?
CHARLES: I think it's about thinking through
your entire workflow and making it so that
there are multiple ways of approaching it
and multiple ways of getting through it. So,
for example, you don't really want to build
a program that says you must use a mouse to
drive it.
EVE: Mmhmm
CHARLES: Instead, think of the task, right?
Something as simple as, say, a drag-and-drop
operation. If you made it so that the only
way to add something was via drag and drop,
then you have a serious accessibility problem.
Because for a user with physical impairments
who can't use a mouse, or for a blind user
who wouldn't be able to use a mouse and aim
it properly, it will not work for that audience.
However, if you expanded-- if you took a step
back and thought about the problem you're
trying to solve, which is to get the user
intent of: they take something from bucket
A and they're moving it into bucket B; if
you then think of the problem in that sense,
then you have a lot of options open. Because
then it doesn't necessarily have to be drag-and-drop.
Drag-and-drop is one of the ways of moving
something from A into B, but you could also
do it by keyboard by selecting it first and
then doing a cut-and-paste operation. So really
it's about thinking through the problem that
you're trying to solve and then thinking through
multiple ways of letting the user indicate
what they wish to do and conveying the results
back to the user and not forcing them into
just one mode of doing things.
VINT: Do you suppose now that we're beginning
to see computers getting better and better
and actually understanding speech, that we
will get into a more conversational interaction
with some of these applications so we can
actually tell it what it is we're trying to
accomplish and have it figure out the best
way to do that?
CHARLES: I certainly hope so. That's one of
the things that I think is really cool about
technologies like Google Now and some of the
things that we've shown off at Google I/O.
The nice thing, too, is I think we really
want to think a step ahead of just the computer
doing exactly what the user said, but rather
having some level of anticipation and assistance
so that the user doesn't necessarily have
to mechanically go through every individual
step, but rather have a smoother workflow
where they can perform a task and have efficient
task completions.
EVE: From what you describe, Charles, it sounds
like doing things that help people with accessibility
needs has the potential to help everybody
streamline what they're doing on the computer.
CHARLES: Bingo.
VINT: That's a really good point.
CHARLES: And that's really something that
I think everyone should strive for.
EVE: Thank you.
CHARLES: Thanks, Eve.
EVE: So jumping up one level, I want to come
back to something, Vint, that you touched
on earlier. You mentioned, in other words,
that the internet is supposed to level the
playing field for everyone. Can you comment
a little bit more on that?
VINT: Well, I think as Charles has just demonstrated,
the internet is filled with boulders and mountains
that have to be either climbed or moved in
order to make it - moved, preferably - to
make it a really level playing field. What
I found most interesting about Charles' demonstration
is the level of detail with which you have
to think in order to imagine what your software
is going to be like for someone who's blind.
You have to similarly try to think your way
through what happens if you have a user who's
deaf or has some other impairment. What I
think is fundamental here - and the reason
it's important for this class to be taken
by everyone who's interested in making web
experiences useful for everyone - is the degree
to which you have to imagine how this is going
to behave for someone who needs assistance.
This is all about harnessing the computer
power that we know is in those boxes to help
someone who needs a little bit of assistance
to experience the web in a way that is needed
for that particular person. The thing I want
to emphasize here is the diversity of assistance
needs. It's not a simple thing to say, "I
will do it this way for anyone who has a vision
impairment, and I'll do it this way for someone
who has an audio problem." In fact, every
single person with one of these variable challenges
may need different nuances - different kinds
of assistance. And so we need a lot of flexibility
built into this environment. It's also, I
think, very important not to imagine that
you can build a web application and then somehow
sprinkle accessibility pixie dust on it and
have it work. It's much more fundamental than
that, and that's why this class is so important.
So I want to encourage everyone who has a
desire to make their web pages and their other
applications accessible to everyone, to take
this class, absorb what you learn from it,
and then apply it. Because that will, in fact,
make the internet be for everyone.
EVE: Thank you for watching. This is the end
of our GDL on our new course, Introduction
to Web Accessibility. To close us out, Vint,
what should people watching this GDL do next?
VINT: That's easy. Sign up for the class,
take it, absorb it, and apply it!